est ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'aujourd'hui dans son côté héroïque
c'est la fameuse phrase de françois
fillon qui imagine le général de gaulle
mise en examen alors là oui je pense
qu'en plus il se trompe c'est à dire que
le général de gaulle aujourd'hui serait
mis en examen comme tout le monde
à l'époque c'est quand même tout à fait
un autre monde mais de médiapart existe
pas le canard enchaîné existe mais ne
fait pas dans kate
bref un journaliste d'al ismailya le rtf
lui appartient quand il vient il sait
les réponses à l'avance pourrait lui
poser
personne ne lui parle jamais de l'argent
de la françafrique des polices pas mal
personne non mais ça c'est à dire qu'on
est dans une démocratie qu'on
qualifierait aujourd'hui d'autoritaire
oui une démocrature alors c'est sûr
c'est que je pensais de la petite
personnel on pouvait pas il y avait rien
à dire vous pouvez investiguer autant
qu'on voulait sans doute d'une intégrité
bon nsany gens qui étaient autour de lui
il était pas moralement but valable que
ceux qui sont autour doté autour de
mitterrand à sarkozy de volant nous ou
de macron fait le héraut de celui qui
tire les gens vers le haut d'un type
ordinaire vous faites vous fait un
compagnon de la libération que s'il n'ya
pas le aubin vos rivaux mais des griots
potentiel il y en a autant que des vrais
ce que je vous dis ce que je veux dire
ribot et les mains il arrive dans une
société de se dire où les s de nos égos
sont tout ce que nous promet la publ a
souhaité de consommer ce que je veux
dire c'était plus facile à l'époque
d'être d'être le général de gaulle il
l'avait dit lui même le prestige ne va
pas sans mystère car l'on révèle peu ce
que l'on connaîtra le prestige est
encore à portée de la main
on vous filme pas avec un iphone vous
n'êtes pas interviewer partira garçon il
faut ou par yann barthès la nôtre sa
légitimité ne vient pas des urnes elle
vient de l'histoire de l'histoire dans
sa g n le
le mythe vient là de toute façon soit
son autorité était naturel j'ai encore
quand j'ai connu encore quelques-uns non
quand il était en face de vous le fais
pas l'impression d'avoir la chef d'état
il était en face d'un fantôme qui est
porté par la mémoire longue de
l'histoire à ce passage dans ce sens
alors effectivement bondée les scandales
y en a eu mais si vous voulez comme il
savait se tenir a tenu ils se
détestaient au top en pie xii gelé en
ville c'est bien connu mais ils savaient
tous se tenir quand même davantage
et surtout il avait il avait décrit
délais dans le fil de l'épée ce que doit
être un chef la parole vous l'avez lil
wayne qui doit surprendre la parole des
travées solennel mais ils savent plus
tenir il des bond
il passe par les politiques
d'aujourd'hui sont ils sont les pop
alors quand un micro on peut pas on peut
pas les invités entre et encore quand
c'est a dit c'est pour dire des choses
intelligentes mais après un temps c'est
pour dire des conneries il se démonétise
est ce que à quoi faire autrement bien
sûr que oui les films et bien qu'elle
soit portable est bien plus que jamais
au moment dé on est en une époque de
réseaux sociaux et de et d'info en
continu pour échapper à cette espèce
d'europe de l'est ces mères qui fait que
ces décès des kleenex on les utilise les
voilà notabilisé on les utilise et puis
on les jette
il devrait tout en plus maintenir sur
tous les chefs 1 au sommet il essayait
enrôlera
[Musique]